PRESIDENT.
WE WILL HAVE MUCH MORE OF THAT
UNDERCOVER FOOTAGE COMING UP
LATER ON THE SHOW.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION TO
ALL OF TONIGHT'S BIG STORIES,
CAROLINA CONGRESSMAN MIKE
MEADOWS, HOUSE RANKING NUMBER
NUMBER, --
MARK, YOU KNOW, SCHIFF HAS A LOT
OF PROBLEMS HERE.
NO WONDER THE NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER LIGHTED ALL
CONTACT.
I GUESS HE DOESN'T WANT HIM TO
COME.
NANCY PELOSI IS CURRENTLY
DOESN'T HAVE THE VOTES FOR A
REAL INQUIRY.
I WOULD SAY THEY WILL PROBABLY
HAVE A HARD TIME IMPEACHING EVEN
OTHERS NOTHING HARD TO IMPEACH
OVER A PERIOD >> OBVIOUSLY
NANCY PELOSI DECIDED TO NOT PUT
A RESOLUTION ON THE FLOOR WHICH
WOULD HOPEFULLY START THE
PROCESS OF IT BEING FAIR.
I CAN TELL YOU, JIM AND I HAVE
BEEN NOW AND OVER 40 HOURS OF
DEPOSITION AND WHAT WE ARE
FINDING IS THAT ADAM SCHIFF ONLY
WANTS TO HAVE WITNESSES WHO WILL
GIVE THE RESPONSE THAT HE HOPES
THAT THEY WILL GIVE AND EVEN AT
THAT, IT'S A SWING AND A MISS.
YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND WE CALL IT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER BUT IT'S REALLY
MORE OF AN ANONYMOUS INFORMANT.
WE NEED TO HAVE THEM COME IN SO
THAT WE CAN SAY, HOW OFTEN DID
YOU COORDINATE WITH ADAM SCHIFF?
DID HE HELP YOU IN FILING THIS
SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWER
COMPLAINT?
WHY DID YOU NOT LET EVERYONE
KNOW THAT YOU HAD CONTACT WITH
CONGRESS?
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF QUESTIONS
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
JUDGE FOR THEMSELVES.
>> Sean: JIM JORDAN, YOU'VE
BEEN WATCHING THE CIRCUS NOW GO
ON FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS.
EVERYTHING THEY ACCUSE THE
PRESIDENT OF, THEY THEMSELVES
ARE GUILTY OF.
OKAY.
LOOK AT SCHIFF.
IS HE COMPROMISE?
DO YOU THINK HUNTER BIDEN IS
COMPROMISED?
OR JOE BIDEN?
IF COUNTRIES MAKE ALL OF THESE
GREAT DEALS, MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS, FOR HIS SON TO DO
NOTHING WITH NO EXPERIENCE, I
GOT TO IMAGINE THEIR THINKING
THAT THEY ARE PROBABLY GOING TO
GET FAVORABLE TREATMENT FROM
THEIR FATHER.
THAT'S JUST A GUESS OF MINE.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ANNA MARK IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
NANCY PELOSI AND ADAM SCHIFF ARE
TRYING TO IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES 13 MONTHS
BEFORE AN ELECTION BASED ON A
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER WITH NO
FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE WHO --
HE WENT IN FRONT OF --
HE WENT TO ADAM SCHIFF'S
COMMITTEE FIRST.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER GETS A CALL,
GETS INFO ABOUT THE CALL, WRITES
THE MEMO, AND THEN WADES 18 DAYS
BEFORE HE FILES A COMPLAINT AND
WHO IS THE FIRST PERSON THEY RUN
OFF TO SEE?
ADAM SCHIFF STAFF.
AND THEY DON'T MARK THE FORM
EITHER.
THEY DON'T CHECK THE BOX ON THE
FORM THAT SAYS WE TALK TO PEOPLE
ON CAPITOL HILL.
SO YES, MARK IS EXACTLY RIGHT
BUT WHY DO THEY NOW WANT NOT
WANT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER TO COME
IN?
BECAUSE WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
WHEN DID HE COME TO YOU, WHAT
TOOK PLACE?
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
WHOLE THING, THIS NONPARTISAN
PROCESS THEY ARE UNDERGOING.
>> Sean: OKAY SO WHERE DOES
THIS GO NEXT?
NANCY PELOSI, ALL OF THOSE
DEMOCRATS, THOSE THAT WERE
ELECTED IN DISTRICTS THAT
DONALD TRUMP WON IN 2016, GOT TO
IMAGINE MOST OF THEM ARE SAYING
THIS IS GOING TO DESTROY YOU MY
CAREER, THIS --
MY DISTRICT DOES NOT WANT TO
PLAY INTO THIS MADNESS.
>> WELL, HERE'S WHERE IT'S GOING
TO GO.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO WRITE
A REPORT.
THEY ARE GOING TO COME OUT OF
THE SECRET ROOMS WHERE THEY HAVE
BEEN, WHERE WE BELIEVE THERE
SHOULD BE CAMERAS AND OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS, BUT THEY
ARE GOING TO WRITE A REPORT AND
NOT REPORT IS GOING TO TAKE ONLY
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF THE
INFORMATION, INFORMATION AND
THAT THEY HAVE ACTUALLY TRIED TO
LEAK TO WITNESSES TO CONCLUDE,
AND THEY ARE GOING TO PUT IT IN
THE JUDICIARY AND THEY ARE GOING
TO SAY THIS IS THE MOST CRAZY
THING WE'VE EVER SEEN SINCE THE
MUELLER REPORT AND IT'S TIME TO
IMPEACH AND YET WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SEE
IT FOR WHAT IT IS AND JIM IS
ACTUALLY RIGHT.
WE HAVE AN ELECTION IN 13
MONTHS.
WHAT THE PEOPLE DECIDE IN
NOVEMBER OF 2020.
>> Sean: WILL THEY ACTUALLY
VOTE THOUGH TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT?
>> WELL, WE DON'T KNOW SEAN BUT
MY GUESS IS THE REASON THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE IS NOT
BRINGING IT UP FOR A VOTE TO
START THIS SO-CALLED IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY IS BECAUSE THOSE FOLKS
IN THE DISTRICT THAT
PRESIDENT TROMP WON, THEY'RE
PROBABLY HEARING FROM THEIR
CONSTITUENTS.
THEY'RE PROBABLY SAYING WHAT THE
HECK IS GOING ON?
WE'RE SICK OF THIS.
WHY DON'T YOU START DEALING WITH
THE ISSUES WE CARE ABOUT INSTEAD
OF TRYING TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT WE ALL ELECTED.
WE ALL ELECTED HIM.
67 MILLION PEOPLE HERE AND WE
ELECTED HIM AND IN 13 MONTHS
THEY'RE GOING TO BE AN ELECTION
SO WHY ARE YOU DOING THIS?
I THINK THAT'S THE REASON THE
SPEAKER IS HOLDING BACK.
>> SEAN, JIM IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
I WAS WITH GOVERNOR MATT BRENNAN
LAST NIGHT IN LOUISVILLE,
KENTUCKY, AND WHAT WE ARE
HEARING IS NOT JUST IN
NORTH CAROLINA BUT KENTUCKY AND
ALL OVER IT.
PEOPLE ARE OUTRAGED THAT SOMEHOW
THEIR VOICES GOING TO BE TAKEN
AWAY BY A FEW DEMOCRATS IN A
SECRET ROOM.
IT'S JUST NOT AMERICAN AND IT'S
NOT --
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY?
WEREN'T THEY THE SAME AMERICAN
PARTY WANTED TO PULL THE MUELLER
REPORT AND RELEASE IT A WEEK
BEFORE WE SAW IT?
>> THEY WOULDN'T LET MACK A ZEN
YESTERDAY, MEMBER OF THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS, MEMORY